>> Neil: ALARMS GOING OFF IN
TOKYO EARLIER TODAY AND
OVERNIGHT ON WORD THAT THE NORTH
KOREANS LAUNCHED A MISSILE
FLYING OVER JAPAN.
IN CASE YOU'RE SAYING WAIT A
MINUTE, I'VE HEARD THIS BEFORE,
YOU HAVE.
IT'S HAPPENED TO SOUTH KOREA AND
ELSEWHERE IN THE REGION AND
GETTING TO BE A MORE COMMON
EVENT.
GENERAL JERRY BOYKIN IS HERE
WITH US.
HE'S LATEST RUN AWAY SELLER,
"STRONG AND COURAGEOUS."
HERE WE GO AGAIN, GENERAL.
THIS IS SCARY HERE.
WOULDN'T HAVE TAKEN MUCH FOR
SOMETHING TO GO WRONG AND ALL OF
A SUDDEN WE'RE DEALING WITH
SOMETHING FAR MORE TRAGIC.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> AS IMMATURE AND CHILDISH AS
IT MAY SOUND, THIS IS ABOUT KIM
WANTING TO GET BACK ON
EVERYBODY'S RADAR.
IT'S REMEMBER ME, I HAVE NUKES,
TOO.
THIS IS FRIGHTENING THOUGH.
THEY HAVEN'T DONE A TEST LIKE
THIS IN QUITE SOME TIME.
IT GOES BACK TO MAYBE 2018 TO
WHERE THEY FLEW OVER ANOTHER
NATION.
THEY NORMALLY GO UP IN A VERY
HIGH ARC SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO
DO THAT.
THIS ONE WAS CLEARLY A DIFFERENT
THING ALTOGETHER.
I'M CONCERNED THAT HE'S BECOMING
MORE BELLIGERENT AND THAT SHOULD
BE A REASON FOR ALL OF US TO BE
A LITTLE CONCERNED ABOUT HIM.
>> Neil: THEN WE DO THESE JOINT
EXERCISE WITH SOUTH KOREA.
YOU JUST GOT A LOT OF PRESENCE
IN THE REGION.
SEPARATELY YOU HAVE CHINA
CONTINUING TO INTIMIDATE OFF OF
THE SHORES OF TAIWAN.
THERE'S A LOT THAT COULD GO
WRONG.
>> THERE IS INDEED A LOT THAT
CAN GO WRONG.
AS YOU SAID, WE'RE RUNNING
EXERCISES RIGHT NOW WITH THE
JAPANESE.
THESE EXERCISES ARE PRIMARILY
GEARED TO AIR POWER, GEARED TO
BOMBING, GEARED TO AIR RAIDS AND
THAT TYPE OF THING.
OF COURSE, KIM IS WATCHING ALL
OF THIS.
HE CAN MAKE SOMETHING OF IT IF
HE CHOOSES TO DO SO.
THE PROBLEM IS ONE
MISCALCULATION ON EITHER SIDE
COULD RESULT IN A HOT WAR THERE.
I WOULD BE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT IF I WAS IN JAPAN OR